we have no question something did happen
how many times and how far did he go
i don't know that's why
we ask you to come in so you can tell us
exactly what happened
nothing
charges dropped against the now former
teacher you see being interrogated in
that video good evening thanks for
joining us here at six i'm denise valdez
and i'm brian loftis now at the time of
her arrest police said there may be more
victims but now prosecutors have dropped
their case altogether and the woman
initially accused is talking to the
eight news now i-team our david char is
here with more of the video she wants
you to see
denisa bryant amy villarreal and her
attorney say that video we are about to
play more of shows the detective's
attempt to get her to fess up to
something she says and now prosecutors
agree
just didn't happen
it's hard you know it really does ruin
people's lives 30 year-old amy
villarreal says she has no plans to
return to teaching after a student
accused her of sexual assault i honestly
didn't think it was real villarreal
worked with students on the spectrum
here at crescent academy last september
north las vegas police said a then 16
year old came forward saying villarreal
had taken him off campus at least twice
to have sex in a park he said the
incidents happened two years earlier in
august 2019. now there's no question in
my mind that happened i'm being honest
no question in my mind that something
did happen
how bad it was
how many times it was in this
interrogation video villarreal tells the
detective nothing happened minutes later
that detective claims to have video of
her and the student in her car is there
any reason why we will have video
of you and
in your car
villarreal's attorney warren geller says
there's no reason because there was no
video he also says school records show
villarreal wasn't listed as the
student's provider for that entire month
and worked with the student just three
days in all of 2019. there's only two
days in august of 2019 that she was at
the facility at the same time the
accuser was at the facility just two
days he adds teachers couldn't leave
with students and driving with one
wouldn't go unnoticed i just thought it
was just it just didn't make sense
because where i worked there was no way
i would i was able to take him out
as for next steps villarreal is working
as a personal trainer it ruined my
career
it was hard finding a job it was
something i really enjoyed and it was a
passion of mine i was really good at it
and
i was happy doing what i did
because of qualified immunity it is
unlikely villarreal can sue
investigators north las vegas police did
not have a comment on this case and the
da's office did not respond i'm david
charns live local now